wenn sie über 40% holen jetzt bei der
Landtagswahl ist die Kanzlerkandidatur
dann gegessen für mich ist das Thema
erledigt das ist total erledigt einmal
sie werden nie wieder antreten als
Kanzlerkandidat für mich ist die Sache
erledigt für mich ist die Sache erledigt
ich hatte einen mein Angebot gemacht
dann haben sich eben Mehrheiten anders
ergeben das habe ich zu respektieren und
meine Lebensaufgabe ist Bayern und nicht
nur mein Platz sondern auch meine
Lebensaufgabe das heißt wenn das Angebot
käme würden sie es einfach ablegen mal
abgesehen davon dass es nicht kommt ich
stehe da nicht zur Verfügung das ist ein
klares Wort logisch
[Musik]